今天要聊的這個案例，我一開始看到標題是差點不信。一家公司說他們刻意打破了傳統創業的五個「黃金法則」，然後成功了。
嗯，你可能沒想到的是，這家房地產科技公司在募資初期就被投資人潑冷水，說市場太競爭了。一般創業公司遇到這種情況，通常會想辦法避開紅海。
對啊，照理說大家都會去找個藍海市場。但他們怎麼做的？原文提到他們發現雖然市場很擠，但很多軟體都表現平平，沒有真正的贏家。
沒錯，所以他們選擇反其道而行。他們把目光放在了被大多數人認為「太小」的市場，也就是鎖定那前 1% 的頂級房產經紀人。
我猜啦，一般公司應該不會這麼做，因為前 1% 的客戶雖然含金量高，但數量少，感覺很難快速擴大規模。這也是我最詫異的地方。
其實這點很關鍵。他們選擇為這小眾客戶群打造「高級」軟體和服務。而且更出乎意料的是，他們在募資之前，就已經靠著自身努力達到了一百萬美元的營收。
一百萬美元營收才開始募資，這很特別耶。那他們具體怎麼辦到的？我看原文說他們沒有盲目追求高估值，也沒有盡可能多募資。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。他們選擇以合理的估值募資，主要是為了找到對的合作夥伴，並減少股權稀釋。他們只募所需，加上緩衝，這讓他們更專注。
這跟我們常聽到的「拿到越高估值越好」完全不一樣。那關於技術合夥人呢？很多新創都說一定要有技術合夥人。
嘿，這家公司的創辦人 Malte Kramer 就是個獨自創業的人。他沒有技術合夥人，而是選擇僱用優秀的工程師。他覺得現在有 AI 輔助，這個論點更站不住腳。
我上次跟一個朋友聊創業，他也說他最大的困擾就是找不到技術夥伴。如果可以外包或僱用，對很多非技術背景的創業者來說會輕鬆很多。
但更讓我好奇的是，他們連「快速行動、打破常規」（move fast and break things）這條都打破了。這不是很多科技公司奉為圭臬的嗎？
這點很有意思。原文說，現在 AI 程式碼工具讓任何人都能快速推出軟體，反而導致大量平庸的產品出現。在他們這種高度信任的行業，穩定可靠比快速更重要。
我覺得這就是從市場角度出發的考量。在房地產這種客戶做出重大決策的行業，容錯率很低。信任是需要時間建立的，出錯反而會很快流失客戶。
沒錯，這讓我想起我樓下那間咖啡店。他們一開始急著推陳出新，結果很多新產品品質不穩，後來反而把老顧客嚇跑了。
還有第五點，他們沒有從低價市場切入來「顛覆」，而是從高端市場開始。這是最讓我感到驚訝的。
對啊，一般做法是先用低價搶佔市場，再慢慢往上走。但他們卻反過來，先服務頂級客戶。這會不會讓他們在擴展市場時遇到困難？
效果到底能不能持久，我覺得還有待觀察。不過原文解釋說，這些早期的高端客戶給了他們深入的產品知識、良好的聲譽和有力的推薦，反而帶他們走得更遠。
所以如果我們是創業者或主管，可以從這裡學到什麼？是不是要跳脫那些看起來很「常規」的建議？
我會說，別把任何建議都當成聖經。應該先問問這些建議背後的「情境」是什麼，然後判斷是不是真的適用於自己的情況。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念能不能帶到工作或生活中？
其實，我們工作中也常遇到一些「潛規則」或是「過去的做法」。或許也可以像這樣，去思考這些規則的由來，然後看看是不是有機會用出乎意料的方式去解決問題。
嗯，像是「加班才代表認真」這種想法，可能也有打破的空間。好像也提醒了我們，有時候，反向操作可能反而會找到新的出路。